[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ty trust era is underway in the U.S
Keen to curb corporate power Joe Biden
has appointed officials set on
challenging companies that have grown to
dominate swaits of the American economy
Jonathan Cantor heads the department of
Justice's Anti-Trust division Lina Khan
chairs the Federal Trade Commission and
Tim Wu advises the White House on
competition policy they were all known
as Big Tech critics lamenting
insufficient antitrust enforcement but a
new industry has now emerged as a
potential Target private Equity despite
controlling chunks of U.S Commerce after
pouring trillions of dollars across
sectors from Health Care to housing and
Manufacturing buyout groups have
historically skirted antitrust scrutiny
but their frenzied deal making and
bulging portfolios have now caught the
eye of Washington's new generation of
progressive officials they are concerned
with wall Street's roll-up strategy and
the buy strip and flip model whereby
undervalued companies are acquired
restructured and quickly sold off
the doj and FTC have also set their
sights on buyout groups acquiring assets
companies are ordered to sell in order
to complete other mergers as well as
interlocking directorates where private
Equity Executives sit on Boards of
competing companies
the agencies argue the traditional
application of antitrust laws misses
buyout groups anti-competitive Behavior
because their portfolios involve
multiple deals that relate to each other
in a multitude of ways now they could
Usher in new interpretations of
competition laws and potentially bring
Monopoly cases against fire groups that
could involve criminal charges
detractors say the trio is politicizing
antitrust they argue competition laws
were not written to challenge the
private Equity model or its impact on
social groups an issue raised by FTC
studies supporters praised this new
cohort for standing up to corporate
Titans and for shining a light on
private equities anti-competitive
conduct the agencies have yet to bring a
test case but their stance has already
spooked private Equity firms which have
scrambled to lawyer up and hire PR
Executives to counter Washington's
narrative
if U.S officials make Goods under pledge
to crack down on buyout groups we could
soon see the biggest antitrust showdown
in the history of private equity
[Music]